today we're going to continue our
conversation about
uh monopoly and corporate power with
david dayan who's the executive editor
at the american prospect
and also author of the new book
monopolize life in the age of corporate
power
it's great to have you on david yeah
great to be here thanks
so we recently spoke to tom hartman a
little bit who's also written about
um monopoly and he
looked very very closely at some of the
history of monopoly
power in the united states maybe we
could start with you
with the sort of where we are today what
what are the industries and areas
where monopoly power seems to be sort of
the prevailing force
or or or other areas of american life
i think it would be easier to tell you
what industries aren't
okay because it's uh
it's a very pervasive situation uh
basically look across the landscape of
america and
and all of these sectors of the economy
and you find
more concentration and more
consolidation and that stands to reason
because
uh 40 years ago we kind of stopped
enforcing uh anti-trust law
and and anti-monopoly law and and this
is the result
so you have you know four banks that
control about 60 percent of all deposits
for
airlines that control 80 percent of
domestic routes
you have concentration in hospital
networks where
locally uh uh in metropolitan areas
about
ninety percent of those are highly
concentrated
uh you have obviously pharmaceutical
monopolies the monopoly is granted by
the government
uh you have facebook and google and
amazon
all predominant in their various parts
of the internet search and social media
and e-commerce so
it's hard really to find uh an area that
isn't
tightly concentrated at this stage is
there a
fixed uh sort of uh number that you look
at in terms of x number of firms can
control why percent of the market or
does it really depend on the industry
we're talking about
i mean technically speaking there is
there's this thing called the herfindahl
hershman index
which you don't have to know about
anymore but it basically means
uh it sets a number uh above which
uh a certain level uh uh you know a
market is highly concentrated
how you define a market sometimes comes
into play with these
and and uh at the at the level
of enforcement uh sometimes that that
line is drawn very tightly
uh to say well if you're talking about
local
search and this local area uh then maybe
that's not
tightly concentrated but if you look
sort of with your eyes in reality then
yes obviously a market is concentrated
um you know there used to be
much uh more uh precise standards around
this that
uh there were market share thresholds
where
uh if if the justice department saw that
a company owned more or controlled more
than 30
of a market or 35 or some number uh that
they would step in
and move to break up that that that
industry or or or deny a merger for
those reasons
uh we don't have that as much today this
performed all hirschmann is very
technical
uh as i say you can draw the line in
various different ways and so
um you know i prefer to look at this
sort of in
on an experiential basis if you go out
in the world
and uh you know you go into your
supermarket aisle and you see the same
uh it looks like a lot of uh different
choices but a lot of them are made by
the same companies
uh if you you know try to rent a car go
on a flight or
or you know do the things that you do
throughout your day
you find that there's more and more
concentration within
those sectors and those service
providers i think
a lot of people if asked what's the
concern
about monopoly power overwhelmingly
people would say well if few firms
control a market they can drive up the
price that i pay
for a good or a service but it goes well
beyond that doesn't it
yes it does uh i mean it doesn't go
beyond that in terms of how the justice
department and the federal trade
commission look at things that they have
now this sort of
consumer welfare standard and that has
really been devolved into price
where if if prices are expected to go
down
they approve the merger but there's so
much
more that goes into it you're talking
about quality uh
you know there's no incentive to to make
a service better
if uh there's only one option that a
person has
uh when you're talking about disruption
of
supply chains and disruption of service
uh that magnifies
when there are only a few providers uh
you look at
airlines that glitch
often their computer systems and they
shut down thousands of flights in a
cascading fashion that wouldn't be as
much of a problem
if there were many service providers
many airline carriers
uh that were uh you know doing flights
all around the nation
uh you look at inequality and
uh uh particularly regional inequality
if uh the large firms on the coast are
sort of
extracting all the wealth from uh
areas uh that are uh you know said to be
left behind
then uh that creates a regional
imbalance which has
implications not just for the economy
but for our politics
uh if you uh think about innovation
uh the if you have large firms that
don't want
competitors they essentially sit on
innovation and find
innovators and either copy their their
uh efforts
or or squash their efforts or just buy
them out and then put them away
in the book i talk about a number of
these uh
uh possibilities and and and and
circumstances uh where price is not the
main driver of what the harm is
uh from monopoly and so i i think
there's a tremendous amount
uh of implications to a more
concentrated system
i want to try to draw a little bit of a
distinction
maybe between some industries and others
and kind of see
where you come out on this in thinking
about airlines for example
airlines are a little different than
some other industries
in that the capital required because
you're talking about
outrageously expensive airplanes uh
the capital required is much higher than
in certain other industries like for
example to open a local bookstore which
might eventually be driven out of
business by amazon
can you talk a little bit about what
type of changes or solutions you would
like to see
within the airline industry because it
seems very tough
to do anything other than break
up airlines once they get too big
because the barriers to entry to begin
with are just so high
i mean what you're talking about there
uh and and you see this
in utilities for example so it doesn't
cost it's not cost effective to run
seven different wires to a particular
residence and have that person pick and
choose between the best service
right that's just that just would be
completely cost prohibitive
so what do we do with utilities we
heavily regulate them
so that they have a natural monopoly
but uh we we put them in a situation
where they're not gouging customers
where they're not providing substandard
service
uh and things like that and so you can
sort of extend that out the regulated
public utility model
and it actually uh historically is how
we handled airlines
in the 1930s we had a a a regulating
board called the civil aeronautics board
that said okay
you can you can have a certain amount of
profit for a certain
uh level of capacity on your airline
but you also have to serve the entire
country you have to
make sure that if you live in topeka
kansas
or if you live in uh portland maine
you have access to airlines uh
and and and and flights and travel uh
that allows us to connect the entire
country together
what we did in the 1970s we deregulated
the airlines
uh this led at first to an explosion of
competition actually
but then it all uh it was it was it was
not a virtuous competition everyone was
lowering and lowering prices and then
they
completely cost ineffective and then you
had this this
giant amount of mergers and now what we
have with the hub and scope
spoke model is that certain cities have
been just completely left behind
they there just is no airline service to
large sections of the country and
certainly not direct flights
uh and as cities like cincinnati and
and and others have have seen their
their international airports sort of
wither and then seen
businesses who who rely on business
travel
leave those areas and and move to
larger parts of the country so this this
sort of with the flick of a wrist and
and the change of a
where a hub is you can turn a city from
a a world-class city into
a second-class city and what the civil
aeronautics board did
was it it was trying to prevent that it
was trying to
sort of level the playing field and so
what i think needs to be done
is that when you have businesses like
airlines or utilities
uh you regulate them in such a way
that provides the most service to the
most people
uh with with the least disruption and
so airlines is actually a very good
model for this concept
of a regulated public utility can you
talk a little bit about
which uh industry monopolies
have been exposed through coronavirus
specifically are there are there certain
specific areas we should be looking
where
the the virus and the pandemic have sort
of shined a light on hey
this industry that industry is very much
under monopoly control
well i think what's happened is it's
accelerated
uh uh trends that we've seen for the
last 40 years
for combination of factors number one
it's simply the case that small
businesses do not have the kind of cash
reserve that large businesses do and
we've seen
thousands tens of thousands of small
businesses go under
thereby giving more market share to the
large incumbents
uh the second reason is the cares act
which provided a massive amounts of
support for
large businesses particularly those uh
were public
publicly traded companies uh by propping
up asset prices
whereas small businesses got this ppp
which is an
eight week uh fund for uh
funding payrolls uh obviously we're in
the six months
month of this pandemic so eight weeks
was definitely not enough
and this imbalance has led to more and
more
uh market share going towards the top
and then the third thing
is uh the the changes in sort of
are our patterns of life uh working from
home
uh doing deliveries that has benefited
the large incumbents like amazon
like uh uh certainly the the the
technological uh uh things like
skype what we're using now which is a
division of microsoft or
google tools or things that people are
using to make the work from home process
work uh so you know i think
i think what i would say is it's
accelerated this trend
uh and now we're at a position where
five major tech stocks
are roughly one quarter of the value
of the entire s p 500 which has never
been seen before in history so we're
we're getting into this position with
fewer and fewer
uh companies controlling more and more
of the economy and it's very dangerous
for all the reasons that we've outlined
in the sort of limited time we have left
what do you think is responsible for
getting the us
away from breaking up monopolies and
and actually it's not even about uh
creating law
really just enforcing the laws that that
are there and were enforced more
strictly for
for a time is it as simple as regular
regulatory capture
and um the connections between the
political system
and these corporations or is it more
more complex than that
you can really boil it down to one man
and that man is named robert bork
uh he was the former reagan nominee for
the supreme court he was a failed
uh uh nominee uh for the supreme court
but he had much more impact
uh outside of of the federal bench uh
he wrote the book the antitrust paradox
in 1978 which sort of brought us
this consumer welfare uh uh
prism through which to to view mergers
uh his idea was as long
as a merger makes uh uh the merged
company more efficient then we should
allow the merger
and his corollary was that any merger
makes a company more efficient so it was
perfectly tautological reasoning
that that essentially made it impossible
to stop a merger
and it was internalized by both the
anti-trust authorities the justice
department changed its guidelines in
1982 based on borkian principles
and also the federal judiciary which
internalized these concepts as well
so uh thanks to bork and and and the
ideas that he brought forward with the
law and economics
movement which uh you know was largely
uh out of the university of chicago
uh we we have you know changed and
reinterpreted
all of these century-old anti-trust laws
without really changing a word
what is what is changing now is we're
starting to get an awareness of that
uh and there's sort of a nascent
movement of thinkers and journalists and
and and uh academics who are pushing
back
finally on on this sort of borkian
concept
of antitrust and uh we're starting to
see this bubble up into the political
system
uh you know in july we had the house
antitrust subcommittee
have the the ceos of all the major tech
companies in for
hearing which was very aggressive as to
their anti-competitive harms
that they were placing on on businesses
and uh
partners that work with them as well as
the public
uh so i think the way that we're going
to counteract this
is through a political movement uh
that's really the only way that that the
antitrust laws got put in place in the
first place
and it's the only way that we're going
to get a a re-reinterpretation of them
if you will
uh to restore the concepts
that were brought forward initially with
these laws which was to
protect and preserve competition well uh
well said we've been speaking with david
dayan who's the executive director at
the american prospect
the book is monopolized life in the age
of corporate power
david really appreciate your time well
thanks thanks for having me and thanks
for your interest